à chaque missile qui s'abat sur gaza le
mandat de joe biden se complique alors
que les échanges de tirs entre les deux
parties arrivent dans leur seconde
semaine
washington affiche toujours son soutien
à son allié hébreu le président a
également passé deux appels
téléphoniques au cours du week-end et
lors de ses appels il a souligné que le
hamas devait cesser de tirer des
roquettes sur israël et a affirmé une
fois encore le droit d'israël à se
défendre contre les attaques terroristes
d'après les rapports plus de trois mille
roquettes ont été tirées par le hamas
sur israël au cours des derniers jours
les états unis empêche d'ailleurs
toujours l'adoption d'une résolution
contraignante au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu privant l'organisation d'un de ses
seuls moyens de pression bien que
washington se défendent de toute
obstruction
nous ne faisons pas obstacle à la
diplomatie au contraire comme je les dis
nous l'exerçons pratiquement sans
relâche
la question est de savoir si une action
ni déclaration donnée peut réellement
faire avancer l'objectif de mettre fin à
la violence et d'aller vers un monde
meilleur
une orientation que l'administration
américaine a pourtant de plus en plus de
mal à tenir en cause des voix
dissonantes en provenance du camp
démocrate qui réclame de la part de la
maison blanche une position plus
équilibrée
preuve en est ce courrier signé par 25
représentants démocrates et adressée au
secrétaire d'état anthony blinken
jérusalem est fait partie de la
cisjordanie et au regard du droit
international israël exerce une
occupation militaire de ce territoire
nonobstant son incorporation illégale de
jérusalem-est dans la municipalité de
jérusalem et son annexion illégale d y
aurait ultérieure de jérusalem est
les projets d'israël de démolir des
maisons palestiniennes à albou stands et
d'expulser des palestiniens de leurs
maisons à cheikh jarrah sont en
violation flagrante de la quatrième
convention de genève
deux jours plus tard le très populaire
sénateurs de gauche bernie sanders
enfonce le clou dans une tribune du new
york times depuis des années nous
assistons à une occupation israélienne
croissante de la cisjordanie et de
jérusalem est
et un blocus continue de gaza qui
rendent la vie des palestiniens de plus
en plus intolérable
nous avons vu le gouvernement de
benyamin nétanyahou s'employer à
marginaliser et à diaboliser les
citoyens palestiniens d'israël
nous devons reconnaître que les droits
des palestiniens sont importants la vie
des palestiniens comptent palestinian ce
live matters une tournure parfum
particulier outre-atlantique
illustration de cette nouvelle tendance
politique cette vente à israël pour 735
millions de dollars de bombes à guidage
de précision et qui a suscité une levée
de boucliers démocrate au congrès ces
appels à plus de sévérité à l'égard de
netanyahu joe biden ne peut les ignorer
le président américain ne disposent au
sénat que de la plus courte majorité
possible tout mécontentement de son camp
l'empêcherait d'appliquer son programme